uh what I can say is that if NATO allies
and especially of course
the big ones starts to issue security
guarantees uh bilaterally to Ukraine we
are very close to Article Five uh so
this is a this is there's no way to to
to find an easy solution to these issues
the most important thing is to be very
strong in our support Ukraine so Ukraine
Prevail as a sovereign strong
independent nation in Europe
so
let's discuss a bit the commitment by
NATO allies to to invest sufficiently in
defense as you know
in Wales at the nature summary in Wales
back in 2014 we decided that within the
next decade all allies would live up to
invest at least two percent of GDP in
defense
when we read your latest annual reports
and we see that only seven
allies
live up to that
two percent Target into in 2022
that's very disappointing so the
question is
how would you address this issue in
Vilnius how would you press
the Allies to actually live up to their
commitments
from 2014.
well as you know honest the decision in
Wales in 2014 was
something that was not easy to reach you
were done Secretary General when that
decision was made and I am very glad
that when I came in we had that decision
as as his starting point uh but of
course it reflected that somalies were
very eager to move faster two percent
and and Beyond and other allies were
very reluctant so whether it's good or
bad where we are now depends a bit on
whether you you assess the glass as half
full or half empty the reality is that
since 2014 we have come a long way on
defense spending even though I would
have uh very much appreciated NATO Alice
to have done even more because before
2014 Alice across Europe and Canada were
reducing defense spending since 2014 all
allies have increased defense spending
so more than others but all have gone
from going down to going up which is a
huge difference
uh we are more than trouble the number
of allies meetings that you present uh
Target and even those are not yet at two
percent they have now plans in place to
be there within a few years for instance
Germany they're not at two percent but
but the increase they have already
started started to deliver and makes a
huge difference because of the size of
of Germany and because of the site 100
billion that has been set aside that
enables them to reach two percent uh
soon
um then the challenge was that
since there were different views in in
Wales the language is a bit it it
although the language says that we
should aim to move towards to present uh
and uh and and for some allies they
interpreted that as a kind of ceiling we
should move towards uh I hope that in in
in Vilnius we will be able to uh agree a
much stronger commitment meaning that we
should not refer to two percent as
something we aim towards uh to move
towards but we should have two percent
as as not this not not the ceiling but
the floor a minimum uh that all Allah
should deliver immediately not within a
a decade and uh if anything the war in
Ukraine has demonstrated for all allies
that need to invest more in events so I
welcome the progress we have made I want
to see even more I'm certain that at
three minutes will have a stronger
commitment to investing more in defense
when when should they meet that floor
that should be immediately and so
instead of having a kind of a decade
long long uh perspective because 2014 is
of course different than 20 23 and
things have changed if any as a repeat
as an allies realized in in August 2014
when the white Summit was held that we
lived in a more dangerous world but it's
even more obvious now with a massive
aggression of uh or by by Russia against
the Ukraine so again it's not for me to
decide this text will be negotiated I
will put for my proposals I will push
hard for allies to agree something which
is stronger uh referring to two percent
as a minimum and we don't have a decade
loan but it should be something that
should be it should be reach also as
soon as possible immediately without
waiting uh more than absolutely
necessary do you think that 2030 is as
soon as possible
well it will vary it's because Summer
allies are you know quite far away from
two percent and of course there's no way
to double a defense spending in one a
year but all their allies and more and
more allies are now quite close to two
percent and of course they could be
there very soon but the message should
be that there's not not yet another
decade you should all be at your present
as soon as possible that should be the
message from from uh from Williams okay
hey so let me turn a bit to the broader
worlds in the new strategic concept NATO
addresses uh the challenges from China
and among other things you write in the
new strategic concept we will stand up
for our shared values and the
rules-based international order
including freedom of navigation
so what does this mean in practice could
you imagine a NATO engagement in keeping
the South China Sea or the Taiwan Strait
open for international shipping
well NATO allies are present uh also in
the South China RCM they they sail there
uh with Merchant ships and of course
also sailor with a a military uh uh or
naval ships
[Music]
um
um NATO will remain a regional Alliance
uh uh North America and uh and Europe
but what was clearly stated for the
first time in the Strategic concept we
agreed in Madrid uh last year was that
China matters for our security and and
China poses a challenge opposes a
challenge to our interests or values and
to our security and that's also one of
the reasons why we are now working even
more closely with our Asia Pacific
partners and also why we have so clearly
communicated that
status quo in and around Taiwan should
not be changed by by Force and and uh
and China's threatening rhetoric and
labor against the Taiwan is unjustified
and any differences and and disputes
around Taiwan should be sold by peaceful
means
um okay
my
my last Summit I said to General uh was
the whale Summit in 2014
I don't know if the villner summit
will be your last Summit uh as Secretary
General I I know that you've indicated
this I had to leave NATO and I also know
that it's very much restricted what
you're able to say about this issue but
maybe I could ask you which
qualifications do you think that your
successor should possess
as I have had the privilege of uh
serving as Secretary General Netto for
almost nine years now uh uh and uh and
I'm totally focused on uh on that task
uh until
um my tenure ends in uh in October
um uh it's important for me to not be
part of the discussion about who will
come after me my successor
um so anything I say about that
qualifications or whatever it is will
just be interpreted as I'm going into
discussion I should not be part of I'm
absolutely confident that is
Alliance of close to one billion people
many nations 31 Nations will absolutely
able to find a great successor following
after me
may I switch
my question then jewelry Pride would be
between you and me
um if if allies ask you
to stay on
um I ready to
to continue and celebrate the
75th Anniversary Summit in DC next year
May declare that I I have no other plans
done to to to leave this this fall I
will be in almost twice as long as as
originally planned and uh and uh and
that's what I have to say about that
yeah okay
I would like to to thank you very much
yes you are the head of uh the strongest
organization of Earth
to defend freedom and democracy so thank
you very much for joining us today I
wish you all the best in the run-up to
Vilnius and whatever made happen after
that thank you
looking today